you were saying in an interview that you
think musicians have it worse than
actors what do you think that and kind
of in this Hollywood landscape D the
musicians have it worse than actors well
because I think is a pop star you're a
version of yourself you're presenting a
version of yourself to the world whereas
we're intentionally and applauded for
presenting something that's very
different than ourselves like if you're
if you're accused as an actor of just
doing a version of yourself that's a
negative you know whereas as a pop star
you're that's what you're doing is like
this is me and so I think that if
everything is much more personal if it's
you out there and they're spotlight as
opposed to we get to hide behind
characters that other people right okay
can I ask you to clarify something
because there were I think that there's
some comments that are being
misconstrued about you saying you saw
back in the day Jessica Simpson in a
bikini and were confused about the
message some people are taking that as I
wish that you were shaming what did you
mean by that because I didn't I didn't
take it that way but what did you mean
by that
yeah I would never intend to shame any
anybody and and that was absolutely not
my intention I was really talking about
the mixed media mixed messages that
media puts out there for free young
women and completely apologize for any
hurt it may have caused because that was
definitely not my intention yeah we know
that Natalie Portman is a champion for
women we thank you that I think that's
what when I saw that I was a clone that
I didn't know that
yeah what I said was that I was confused
by mixed messages when I was a young
girl growing up and I think there are a
lot of messages for how women should be
and and and women should be allowed to
do whatever they want and yes I'm using
you for clarifying it though is really
going back to what Natalie said before
about telephones I mean we live in a
crazy time man wait you know things go
out and suddenly they're ping ponged all
over the place and people get miss it's
it's it's crazy that people also then
are allowed to say look this is what I
meant I'm sorry and this is what it was
really many it's Chinese whispers well
here's what I believe like I said when I
think somebody is a
true-blue good person and I know that
you wouldn't do that I want to give you
an opportunity to say because you never
want somebody to walk away from
something feeling our and we can when
you read something on paper or you
didn't hear the person say it it gets
lost in translation so many times yeah
and also it is a mistake to anyone's
name so I should not have I could if I
could have made my message without
naming it's so true what you just said
about about the difference between
saying and reading it I got given this
oh my god my 18 year old daughter sat me
down was like write down you've got to
stop putting dots after your sentences
when you text me and I'm like why that's
me like saying you know like coming home
yeah question and she's like it's really
rude you're upsetting me
what what I mean - or like dinner she's
like yeah you patronizing me like feel
about maybe - I want it I I can realize
as his whole like it worth and then she
started saying it the way it was written
and I was like no ya didn't even know
you guys thank you so much I appreciated
thank you for clarifying
[Music]